cher journal depuis quelques temps je
vois vraiment des signes partout qui me
disent que je vais mourir seul alors je
sais que ça ne veut rien dire qu'on ne
voit que ce qu'on a envie de croire mais
le problème c'est que moi j'ai pas du
tout envie de croire ça je veux qu'on me
rassure je veux qu'on me promettre que
l'avenir sera lumineux et surtout qu'on
serait minimum 2 alors je suis allé voir
une voyante
bonjour bonjour
installez-vous je reviens dans un
instant 1 nous voilà alors qu'est ce qui
vous amène s'offrir le savoir non c'est
qu'en fait depuis quelques temps je vois
vraiment des signes partout qui me
disent que je vais mourir seul et ça
m'angoisse un peu je voulais savoir si
c'était vrai c'est impossible
ah bon les animaux parlent pas ah non en
fait quand je lis des signes je veux
dire des symboles est la seule à pouvoir
faire de l'humour vous un homme ou une
femme
une femme souhaitez-vous souscrire à
notre newsletter non j'avais merci
[Musique]
dites moi parce que vous mangez que je
sache qui vous êtes
oui bah ce matin j'ai mangé du pain
perdu hier j'ai mangé quoi des légumes
oubliés j'ai fait ça et ce qui me reste
dans mon frigo jeu quelques trucs
périmés mais ça va on peut encore les
manger un bon bientôt expirer êtres
sagittaire non bélier gémeaux non vierge
ouais ça se voit tout de suite elle m'a
fait tirer les cartes
apparemment c'est infaillible
celle là
voilà
celle ci
intéressant vous allez fuir une
situation très inconfortable
vous êtes sûr que tu avais pas plutôt
dire que je vais mourir seul puisque là
vraiment ça me voulait prendre la place
peut-être finalement je suis contente
d'y être allé je le recommanderais
autour de moi à celles et ceux qui ont
besoin d'arrêter les croire n'importe
quoi mais vais y aller merci beaucoup en
tout cas
même journée
[Musique]
j'ai tout de suite vu qu'elle allait
faire une situation inconfortable